IT'S 5 O'CLOCK IN NEW YORK CITY
AND THIS IS "THE FIVE."
>> ♪ ♪
>> THE BOOK THAT SHOOK
STORES AT MIDNIGHT DESPITE CEASE
MICHAEL WOLFF APPRECIATED THE
PRESIDENT.
>> HE IS HELPING YOU SELL BOOKS?
>> ABSOLUTELY AND HELPING ME
PROVE THE POINT OF THE BOOK.
>> THE WHITE HOUSE CALLS "FIRE
AND FURY" A WORK OF FICTION.
PRESIDENT TRUMP SAID HE NEVER
SPOKE TO HIM FOR HIS PHONEY
BOOK.
FULL OF LIES AND REPRESENTATIONS
INTERVIEW DENIAL.
>> I ABSOLUTELY SPOKE TO THE
PRESIDENT.
BUT IT WAS NOT OFF THE RECORD.
>> YOU SPOKE TO HIM AT THE WHITE
HOUSE AFTER HE WAS SWORN IN?
>> I SPOKE TO HIM AFTER THE
INAUGURATION, YES.
I HAVE SPOKEN -- I HAVE SPENT
ABOUT 3 HOURS WITH THE PRESIDENT
OVER THE COURSE OF THE CAMPAIGN
PRETTY SIGNIFICANT.
>> WHY DON'T WE SEE IF SARAH
SANDERS CAN SETTLE IT.
>> THEY SPOKE ONCE BY THE PHONE
FOR A FEW MINUTES.
IT WASN'T ABOUT THE BOOK.
THEY HAD A SHORT CONVERSATION.
HE NEVER INTERVIEWED THE
PRESIDENT ABOUT THE BOOK.
HE MAKES IT SOUND LIKE HE WAS
NOT THE CASE.
THIS IS A GUY WHO MADE UP A LOT
OF STORIES TO SELL BOOKS.
MORE AND MORE PEOPLE ARE
TAKE ON RECENT DEVELOPMENTS, THE
NEW NICKNAME AND WHERE DOES
SLOPPY STEVE RANK WITH TRUMPS
NICKNAMES?
>> IT'S NOT AS GOOD AS
POCAHONTAS.
BUT IT'S PRETTY GOOD.
IT CONJURORS UP THE IMAGE OF A
IT IN A BIG MESSY SANDWICH.
IT'S NOT SOMETHING I WOULD BE
HAPPY WITH IF I WAS STEVE
BANNON.
>> GERALDO, THIS GUY ONLY GOT 3
HOURS IN THE COURSE OF 9 MONTHS?
>> MORE THAN 9 MONTHS.
THE CAMPAIGN BEGAN IN 2015.
YOU HAVE 3 HOURS.
THAT'S NOT 3 HOURS OF MICHAEL
WOLFF SPEAKING WITH PRESIDENT
TRUMP OR PRESIDENT-ELECT OR
CANDIDATE TRUMP.
THAT'S BEING IN THE PRESENCE OF
WERE A SHRINK AND SAYS THINGS.
YESTERDAY MY WRATH WAS DIRECT AD
AT THE BENEDICT ARNOLD STEVE
BANNON WHO HAS BEEN A TRAITOR TO
THE FAMILY THAT ENTRUSTED HIM.
TODAY -- AND I DON'T LIKE
CRITICIZING REPORTERS -- BUT
MICHAEL WOLFF SAID SOMETHING
THEY THINK BEGS EXPLORATION.
HE SAID 100% OF THE PEOPLE
AROUND DONALD TRUMP, SENIOR
ADVISORS AND FAMILY MEMBERS,
EVERY ONE QUESTIONS HIS
INTELLIGENCE AND FITNESS FOR
OFFICE."
REALLY?
THIS IS A PATENT LIE!
THIS IS ABSOLUTELY UNTRUE.
AT SOME POINT, EACH PEOPLE ON
THEY QUESTIONED WHETHER HE GOT
ACCESS AT ALL UNDER FALSE
PRETENSES.
SO IVANKA WHO MICHAEL WOLFF SAID
IS DUMB AS ROCKS.
THIS IS NOT TRUE!
IT'S UNFAIR.
IT IS SO SCREAMINGLY INEQUITABLE
TO ACCUSE THE PRESIDENT OF BEING
SOMEONE WHO LACKS INTELLIGENT
AND FITNESS FOR OFFICE AND SAYS
EVERY ONE OF HIS FAMILY AGREES
WITH ME.
>> YOU KNOW FOR A FACT THEY
DON'T THINK THAT.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
IT'S UNTRUE.
>> A LOT OF DISHONEST REPORTING.
THEY LET THE FOX INTO THE
HENHOUSE FOR A LONG TIME.
SALACIOUS REPORT.
>> ONE OF THE THINGS HE SAID
THIS MORNING HE KEPT WAITING FOR
SOMEONE TO SAY WHY ARE YOU IN
THIS MEETING?
IT'S INCONCEIVABLE TO ME THAT
THIS HAPPENED IN THE FIRST
PLACE.
>> THEY DIDN'T HAVE A WHITE
HOUSE COMMUNICATIONS DIRECTOR.
SPICER'S ROLE WAS PRESS
SECRETARY AND COMMUNICATION
DIRECTOR.
IT'S IMPOSSIBLE TO DO BOTH WELL.
THEY DID A DISSERVICE TO THE
PRESIDENT.
WHOEVER DECIDED TO LET HIM IN.
NO ONE SAID I DON'T THINK WE
SHOULD HAVE HIM HERE.
MAYBE THEY DIDN'T KNOW AND
THOUGHT IT WAS PART OF THE SHOW.
THAT SAID, HE WOULD NOT HAVE
ACCESS THE WEST WINGIF HE WAS
NOT GRANTED IT.
>> RIGHT.
CAN STEVE BANNON GRANT HIM THAT
KIND OF CARTE BLANCHE?
>> SURE.
WHAT IS UP?
>> HERE'S ANOTHER THING I DON'T
BELIEVE.
A COUPLE OF PIECES THAT WERE
FLATTERING ABOUT PRESIDENT TRUMP
AND SAYING HOW INTELLIGENT HE
WAS AND HE COULD PIN POINT WHAT
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE WANTED.
THAT'S ONE WAY HE GOT HIS FOOT
IN THE DOOR.
I DON'T BLAME HIM.
THEN WRITES THIS BOOK.
ONE THING ABOUT MITCH McCONNELL.
TAKE A MEETING BECAUSE HE NEEDED
TO GET A HAIRCUT.
HIS OFFICE SAID THAT'S
RIDICULOUS.
THAT NEVER HAPPENED.
THE ONE THING THAT IS A DANGER,
HE HAS NOTES AND RECORDINGS AND
REPORTS.
IF YOU WERE ONE OF THOSE PEOPLE
THAT THOUGHT YOU WERE TALKING TO
HIM OFF THE RECORD AND YOU GET
BURNED IN THIS BOOK, YOU MIGHT
BE REALLY CAUTIOUS ABOUT SAYING
IT NEVER HAPPENED BECAUSE YOU
WOULD BE SUPER EMBARRASSED.
LET IT GO AND MOVE ON.
>> HOW DAMAGING IS IT, GREG?
>> I DON'T KNOW.
HE SAID HE WAS IN TRUMP'S
PRESIDENT FOR 3 HOURS.
I THINK HE WAS TALKING ABOUT 3
THIS IS A PREFERABLE PROBLEM TO
HAVE.
COMPARE TWO SITUATIONS.
WOLFF'S BOOK IS TELLING YOU WHAT
HAPPENED AFTER TRUMP WON.
WHICH BOOK IF YOU WERE DONALD
TRUMP WOULD YOU PREFER TO HAVE?
>> THAT'S A GOOD POINT.
[LAUGHING].
>> I THINK I WOULD TAKE THE
VICTORY BOOK.
DEMOCRATS, YOU ARE LAUGHING AT
IMPULLSIVE LIKE A CHILD.
HOW DOES IT FEEL TO BE BEATEN BY
SOMEBODY LIKE THAT WHO HAS LESS
KNOWLEDGE OF YOUR CANDIDATE.
YOUR POLITICIAN GOT BEATEN BY A
SALESMAN FROM QUEEN.
THAT'S HILARIOUS.
>> THE BIG JUICY GOSSIP HERE.
JESSE AND GERALDO AND I
UNDERSTAND THIS.
THE GOSSIP IS TRUMP IS LIKE A
CHILD.
WE ARE ALL THAT.
EVERY MAN HAS BEEN TOLD BY HIS
WIFE OR WIVES THAT WE ARE
CHILDREN.
MEN WANT THINGS A CERTAIN WAY.
WHO ARE IMPATIENT AND DON'T HAVE
TIME TO READ.
TELL ME WHAT I NEED TO KNOW.
WE ACT LIKE CHILDREN.
I AM REMINDED OF THIS EVERY DAY.
THAT'S A COMPLIMENT.
LIKE A CHILD FROM THE OMEN OR
EXORCIST
EXORCIS
EXORCIST.
>> EVERYBODY BENEATH YOU SAYS
CRAP ABOUT YOU BECAUSE THEY ARE
SUPPOSED TO.
WHEN THERE IS A CHANGEOVER.
WHEN A TEAM IN THE PRE-SEASON IS
UNDER GOING A CHANGE IN
PERSONNEL BECAUSE THEY LOST AND
THEY GET NEW PEOPLE IN.
HALF OF THE PEOPLE ARE JUST
GROUCHY.
THEY ALWAYS END UP GOING.
OTHER PEOPLE STAY.
THERE IS CHAOS IN A CHANGE OF
PERSONNEL.
THIS IS ALL NORMAL.
HE GOT IN THERE AND GOT TO WATCH
IT.
THAT WAS A MISTAKE.
>> THAT'S THE PROBLEM TO BEGIN
WITH.
WHY WAS HE ALLOWED THIS ACCESS
TO WALK AROUND AND LISTEN IN.
OVERHEAR CONVERSATIONS?
TO ME THAT'S UNBELIEVABLE THAT
>> I LIKE DR. EVIL'S GLASSES.
>> THAT'S YOUR NICKNAME FOR
WOLFF?
YOU ARE IN THE MIDDLE OF AN
ADMINISTRATION.
WHEN I WAS DEPUTY PRESS
SECRETARY OF STATE.
KARL ROVE WAS MY RESPONSIBILITY.
A REPORTER FROM A LIBERAL
MAGAZINE SAID HE GETS A BUM RAP
AND I WANT TO DO A PROFILE PIECE
SAYING HE IS GREAT AND SUPER
SMART.
I WAS CHARMED.
I WENT TO THE WHITE HOUSE
COMMUNICATIONS DIRECTOR AND SAID
GIVE HIM A SHOT.
HE SAID KNOCK YOURSELF OUT.
I PULLED OUT ALL OF THE STOPS:
INTERVIEWS, 3rd PARTY BACK UP.
BRUNCH.
I DID EVERYTHING.
THIS PIECE RAN.
IT WAS THE MEANEST THING I HAVE
EVER READ IN MY LIFE, AND IT WAS
MY FAULT.
I HAVE NEVER SPOKEN TO HIM
AFTER.
>> HE'S IN THE DEEP FREEZE.
>> THEY SEDUCE YOU AND TELL YOU
EVERYTHING YOU WANT TO HEAR.
THEY GET IN AND IT'S A HATCHET
JOB.
>> ONE THING WHAT DANA MENTIONED
ABOUT RECORDING IT.
IN MY OPINION DURING THE TIME HE
IS IN THE WHITE HOUSE I DON'T
THINK HE CAN HAVE A RECORDER ON
HIM.
>> ON YOUR PHONE?
>> I KNOW YOU CAN DO IT.
I THINK THIS GUY IS A SCHMOOZIE.
>> OF COURSE YOU CAN RECORD IT.
>> I THINK YOU ARE RIGHT.
>> [OVERLAPPING TALKING].
TONIGHT TELL HIM ANYTHING.
>> HE IS NOT A FRIEND.
>> I DON'T BELIEVE THIS REPORT
THAT JUST CAME OUT THIS
AFTERNOON.
I AM SURE THEY ARE HEARING THIS
BUT I DON'T BELIEVE IT'S TRUE.
IT SAID THAT STEVE BANNON WAS
THINK ABOUT PUTTING OUT A
THE PRESIDENT'S STATEMENT BEAT
HIM TO IT AND I DON'T BELIEVE HE
WAS GOING TO DO THAT.
THE PRESIDENTIAL'S STATEMENT.
>> HE DELAYED AND DIDN'T DO IT.
THAT WAS ONE.
THINGS THAT WAS SAID.
WHY NOT DO IT RIGHT AWAY?
>> THAT'S THE BEST WE COULD DO
THE NEXT DAY.
IF THERE ARE TAPES HE CAN'T SAY
HE DIDN'T SAY IT OR MAKE ALL OF
THESE COMMENTS.
HE KNOWS IF HE SAID IT.
IF THIS GUY RECORDED IT, THE
BEST THING YOU CAN SAY IS THE
PRESIDENT IS A GREAT MAN.
>> I THINK BANNON IS SCREWED
REGARDLESS.
>> COULD YOU IMAGINE IF A
REPORTER LIKE MICHAEL WOLFF WAS
INSIDE THE CLINTON WHITE HOUSE
IN THE '90s?
WITH A RECORDER, WATCHING THE
GIRLS GO IN AND OUT AND WHAT WAS
GOING ON IN THE OVAL OFFICE.
>> THOSE ARE THE TAPES WE NEED.
>> WHAT WAS THE BOOK THAT JUST
CAME OUT ABOUT THE HILLARY
>> "SHATTERED."
AND THE CLINTON CAMPAIGN WAS
BADLY ABOUT EACH OTHER AND ABOUT
THE CANDIDATE.
THESE THINGS HAPPEN AND YOU CAN